don't [ __ ] this up let's go to the
phones see you're already [ __ ] it up
Chad you're already [ __ ] it up and
welcome to punch drunk sports where
winners win we have a Chad sir he's
[ __ ] it up Chad's Chad's a winner
we're excited that Chad Zuma joining us
for as long as Arielle we do you guys
gonna [ __ ] I don't know dude well we
have a hot new podcast called bye Chad
I'm gonna say you have to with Sam now
yeah I know why don't you guys just [ __ ]
Tripoli was a suck a dick so bad well
the thing about that podcast is like I
don't know when he's recording I don't
know what's going on you know that we're
recording right now right yeah like oh
no I haven't listened to one up you're
scared I don't know what I say it's a
great weekend it's Super Bowl weekend
guys it isn't I'm excited there is no
but even though there is no punch-drunk
Super Bowl party our good friends at the
Sycamore tavern are in fact throwing a
big Super Bowl party so we want to
invite you guys down to that hangout
Chad will probably be there since he has
no friends in town so he'll go out there
he'll be local celebrity you know when
they say to like the bench guy from like
like the team to carwash to shake
everybody's hand I'm gonna be nowhere go
home dates whoo you know I purposely
didn't do anything because I wanted to
get acclimated so I don't got anything
coming up and no actually third week in
February I'm with Godfrey at the entero
improv Candace you doing anything
interesting with that freaking baby of
yours okay guys I am at tonight is the
when is this gonna go out today it's
live right now live tonight I am at from
the Comedy Store it is comedy chaos 2
shows 8 o'clock 10:30 Joe Rogan who's on
the first with Joe Rogan Jeffrey Ross
preacher loss and Gerry Dee jessimae
Peluso Eddie Bravo first show
second show Joe Rogan Josh wolf Ian
Edwards Bryan Callen Tony Hinchcliffe
and I believe it man Brian Redman and
then tomorrow night is my new patreon
show for the for tinfoil hat
it is conspiracies now and we have the
block is hot that is downstairs 11 p.m.
at the Comedy Store it's $5 straight
cash only 15 seats available once it's
filled it's filled and then this weekend
I am at the emiting comic strip that's
right Canada I'm coming all weekend
hanging out in a [ __ ] mall like a
goddamn champion
and I do a new also champions do they
get a mom they go to [ __ ] malls okay
so I appreciate you guys come spend
Super Bowl with me go see Santa Sam at
the Cinnabon yes the malls the best up
there because they have like they have
gun ranges and adult books they have a
little adult bookstore where you can go
watch porn my favorite is the stuff you
find it's always so Sam yeah don't worry
I found the adult books and a gun range
of everything in one of the biggest
malls in the world yeah is there a theme
park ever the smallest adult bookstore
it's just a guy with like a [ __ ]
trenchcoat full of like glory hole just
and he also has a gun I say you could
shoot if you want coke crack and glory
hole come on down to them into mall so
that's it a lot of great stuff going on
we're super excited about our lives it
is this week so much to talk about
obviously we want to talk about the big
game Johnny who's over there in his
rightful place
off camera he's given the middle finger
yeah can you pull up the bet DSi we want
getting some of these what are they
called bets the prop prop that's we're
gonna get some prop bets bet DSi for all
your Betty needs go to bet DSi use the
promo code punch 25 and get $25 betting
cash and they will double your deposit
all the way up to $500 they yeah yeah if
you haven't gone to our good friends of
bet deicide that was definitely the week
to do it because
exactly what we're about to talk about
was all these prop bats so we're
literally giving you a free 25 bucks to
just throw on the coin toss you could
bet the length of national anthem you
can bet and who's singing it the
national anthem yet somebody that's
gonna go long I think Gladys Knight was
it maybe yeah no I don't think she will
I would take the under on her because I
think she's older and I don't think she
has that like I think she wants to wrap
this show I'm gonna I'll always you know
Godfrey did my show right yeah I go
Godfrey it's 15 minutes white 15 okay
and uh she's gonna go long
I would Oh black always go over always
go over cuz they're gonna add a little
like but I think I think they're gonna
set that time thinking she's gonna super
black it up but I don't think they're
factoring in and she's also thinking
about somebody say african-american not
play Chad don't please mm you're an Ohio
State Ohio [ __ ] political correctness
to this show okay we're going we're
going to say uh whoa look at that dude
why is it - twenty-five hundred
foreheads
is that crazy why is that that's weird
mild head is wild Oh people always call
heads so I'm gonna go with tails I'm
gonna make these but you're not a
conformist I don't I do die remake the
national anthem here we go and it's
glass night hundred and seven seconds
Jesus hey let's time you singing it do
you know the words
that's not time he said let's have good
audio for one some this episode uh I I
kind of think she's gonna go longer than
that
i'ma go I'm over over 107 I mean 120 is
two minutes two minutes 122 minutes I
take I take over on it I'm going over to
why don't you like you guys always say
and I'm going to six bugs you're going
to six-foot oh you are Wow Jeff job he's
definitely gotta watch he is watching
but I have a season pass and
my best friend are going what a grape
chant place a bang chicks would be Six
Flags Superbowl day right I mean they're
all where any anywhere they're either
single or unloved so they gotta be
they're looking for something usually
I'm neither of those things
you go to any like like like I would say
hipster be like hot kind of bar that's
not showing the game it's gonna be all
like chicks you're you're the only
straight guy there if you want to fish
that's a good time to catch oh where are
you going for that ya know where I
actually care about the Superbowl and
look really robot where would be this
magical place that's packed with my
shelter the rooftop bar mommy shelter uh
absolutely it would be crawling with hot
chicks all day long and not showing the
game yo woman's homeless shelter is
crawling with hot chicks you know you
you don't know that bar no it's like
right by your house it's a [ __ ]
bad-ass bar really rooftop and Hollywood
views of everything are you think it
could be nothing but chicks
I guarantee on the game they're gonna
just have like they're people that don't
care about the game that would be a hit
are literally saying we will not showing
the game there's no TV on the rooftop
there right there's no TV on the rooftop
that's advertisement if you hate
football like we hate football
come here we're not showing the game
they don't even have TVs up there it's
just a rooftop bar that's like girls
love to go to I'm surprised like each
channel or Bravo doesn't do some weird
kind of like runway model I'm already
with you whatever it is I'm right well
they got that Puppy Bowl like a jerk off
to the puppy playing Shahs of Sunset I
see that being like your gym no no no
it's like all the cat ladies we these
chicks are getting so much plastic
surgery I look like cat lady's on the
road sometimes I got beat off to that
[ __ ] that's all I got cuz they're all
wearing [ __ ] yo he's trying to find
these porn rooms I got my porn tracker
that like just basically seats [ __ ]
glory let's turn on your phone or the
computer why do you think this phone
doesn't work I've said high scores on
it's like I'm not
all right moving right along the next
thing will any player take a knee turn
anthem I know
fake no because I think actually if
you're a marginal player would have got
it but if Gladys Knight takes a knee oh
[ __ ]
you know how she got a career by taking
two knees last night sucks [ __ ] oh my
god I didn't will she take two knees if
you know what I mean Oh [ __ ] get hurt
yet pull her teeth out and get a gummy
bear
I don't think cuz I actually think she
got in trouble because I think she went
off on the people taking the knee really
I think she said some [ __ ] about that
you know she's 74 years old she's not
taking a knee she might fall underneath
yeah yeah that's I'll bet on that one
you what I know I'll fist it was this
now razor fist is different because she
could be like and then you have an
argument this is her hand she's Jessie
always this and now we're in the
controversy yeah well I mean like again
Gladys Knight you've always said that
yeah Whitney who spins the ant she
Whitney Houston's I am do you like her
teeth closed her mouth never touched
each other because those [ __ ] White
Fence she has got piano keys in her
mouth I'll give you 15 bucks if you jerk
off to her teeth later he was gonna do
that anyway you're just giving him 15
free bucks
Johnny venmo him oh yeah dude go to my
dude is she Whitney Houston's aunt Oh
Dionne Warwick's it's the same person or
weird I did we lose her oh I thought
they're the same person so happy I'm
glad she's dead Johnny take your hat off
we're talking about Dionne Warwick
I swear to god I'm glad she's dead too
much energy look how dead she is bad
fish Lisa she would do demolition man
before now I got bad juju well I'm glad
Whitney Houston's dead I'll throw that
out there the hotel that she passed away
in I did stand-up there and I bombed so
two people died in that hotel yeah yeah
show that Whitney Houston hotel where's
it up you'd stand up there I am Bob
where where where
where's what city Beverly Hills Hotel
thought you killed to build and Beverly
Hills built around it yeah that's right
he's crazy yeah that's totally you ever
see the old pictures of like when I
think nobody there oh yeah totally
I go by back and buy all the property
that proper yeah of course I can one-up
you my buddy jerked off on the door
handle of the hotel Chris Cornell killed
himself at way way way way way way way
we have a lot of questions no true story
they were jerked off into what they were
doing there was a bachelor party so they
were staying in the hotel and they found
out that this is the Turks off into a
doorknob they were drunk and they took a
bet so he did it he's jerked off on the
door handle was he dog I don't know how
he was doing it there's no door handle
what's it what's it wait what you know
when guys get together they make dumb
bets they're drunk and there's like I
dare you old jerk off Chris Cornell's
door handle like jerk I like look at it
why you beat off does that mean you can
let it go and tell me want to find home
on a door here my god that's just we are
no no we don't even have to ask
I want you to call him and then when he
answers go we're no longer friends and
then hang up on it supposed to do no we
just want to find out what did he do
like how do you jerk off you just stare
at it it's my bucket this is my buddy
who knows the guy who did it okay so now
like yeah like lore and like my buddy
told me the story this guy Chupacabra
was he the [ __ ] weird vampire dog of
Mexico that was jerking off I don't know
that is I don't like this story so bad
for hotel means oh it's your
professionally dealing with come
multiple times oh yeah dude I feel bad I
jerk off into the towels and then I put
water over the towel so they don't not
that yeah I'm afraid to wash it off but
also activate the gist till I cut off
the middleman and the my way till they
come in and start cleaning the room and
I just a jerk off on them you know
what's going on and get your hands out
yeah I will not say their name that will
go on the road and just he was such a
horn dog yeah he would bang the mates oh
you Tara Bryan Callen I don't know who
that is
I don't know anybody about writing
counting from fighter in the kid used to
rape meds
no rape maids dude I just need the rape
that guys those are the ones who do it
no the ones that don't need to do it no
look Darren Sharper that's it nobody
else I'm not blowing up his spot but
mark Normand talked about it on his
podcast bill cosby dude you just blew up
more no he jerked off on his knees onto
his comforter on the bed and just let it
left it there he told on his podcast oh
dude someone said they they were staying
somewhere and there was jizz on the
towels and the only guy the person was
there the week before was Marc Maron oh
that's funny
this is a podcast war I got a funny one
our good friend I won't mention his name
because he has I would like a wife and
kids now but Brian Jarvis was what's his
email he allah jar of 99 he does not a
job does have you
who or a Oh L never get though she like
what are you doing now
what do you do he when he was like
younger and was staying in a hotel he
his girlfriend left whatever but he had
someone had her underwear so he had her
panties on his face and while he while
he was jerking off just had him laying
on his face then he came like all over
himself and then completely passed out
right wakes up with the underwear on his
face and like come on his chest but the
whole room had been clean like the maid
[Laughter]
comes in this room's not going to clean
itself broadcast live halftime show
commercials does not apply keep going oh
we're doing okay I promise back to this
Super Bowl ratings and that's a dumb
thing to do it on hold on stop go down
the neck hold on Super Bowl rates go
down please oh okay I'm mistake
viewership of ratings I would take over
over 6.1 million 6.5 it's in a dead heat
106 million
yeah 106 million that one too okay I
mean that's a third of the country it's
over a third of the country all over LA
and Boston again which nobody's talking
about this is the World Series match up
again yeah that's true I got a prop bet
that okay LeBron James does he show up
and he's he wearing Rams gear Oh with
the slave-owners with the [ __ ] slave
owners does LeBron James show up to the
world to the where the Lakers are they
home no the Lakers they're playing
Golden State the night before now then
no no I'm Tuesday what now they have a
game against the Clippers on Friday I
believe okay so they have now so that's
a big chunk oh the Brahma meter he'll be
there and he's gonna come back to that
Golden State game because he'll be
nationally televised and I'll be at the
Super Bowl the next day I'm telling you
I think
does it what network is showing the
Super Bowl see I think it said CBS right
well no it's Fox CBS so to all be CBS TV
stars that they will cut - well cba we
play the interference covers to the RAM
I mean is that real question I would
that's a hundred percent yes dude can I
bet that now well okay well they dollars
on yes I'm telling you dude no wait wait
wait here's the thing is that during the
actual broadcast of the game about five
and a half hours of previews and prelims
and [ __ ] pickoff [ __ ] so the from the
kickoff yeah I guarantee you I don't I
don't think they would I think they show
it I think they show it 40 times from
noon to 3:30 yeah I would see ball on
the west coast they don't want to like
put that on the game starts I don't
think they want to and by the way we
talked about it we were the first people
to mention this and now it's all over
the news for we said three but it's four
of the officials of that game were from
Los Angeles for Johnny put $1,000 on no
well Jim Nantz say hello friends oh who
gives a [ __ ] about that oh my god Jim
Nantz says hello dude total times Jim
Nantz and Tony Romo say Gronk
two-and-a-half oh absolutely over that
time they say his name every time they
say it not now they're arguing not he
won't say Gronkowski he'll say just say
Grunk a hundred percent they say that
three times if the two of them say it
three times you win that's a win the
greatest idea ever
people love when you do this I've never
had more people [ __ ] on me for something
I never did like if dribbly does is
crossfire voice one more time I'm never
listening to your show again is either
greatest idea ever now Tony Gonzalez's
Tony Romo knocks in all this is in the
group is it a new merit of football
if Tony Romo does what knocks it out of
the park is it about then you mad the
football it's too early for that Tony
Romo and Jim Nance eight dynasty now
here's a funny thing
I wonder if and I know you maybe dabble
in conspiracy talk every now and then I
wonder if CBS and Hillary Clinton go
ahead and the announcers by the way
she's somebody hit me up and said that
she's thing about running for president
again and I go there goes punch-drunk
there goes the podcast podcast now
Hillary gets LeBron James to run with
her that would make hope oh yeah that
would be the end of days oh by the way
we're breaking Erin down and people are
noticing it I love I wonder if they look
at this [ __ ] I wonder if they look at
prop bats we're like that go hey will
Jim Nantz and Tony Romo say dynasty so
Jim Nantz and Tony Rome will get
together saying we're not going to do it
or or $1,000 or CBS has a [ __ ]
somebody that looks at all these prop
bats and goes if I was Jim Nantz and
Tony Romo I get together and say we're
not gonna say and put down $10,000 Tony
Ramos an illegal Oh what the bet on
saying a word well to to say hey dude
let's not say this and let's each bet
$1,000 yeah that would be illegal how
but I would do the [ __ ] out of it I
would have I would like have my neighbor
or something something something
somebody you know right yeah I would go
how do you get in trouble if I throw
five I'd have my neighbor throw five
grand on it and I'll give you a thousand
bucks and we're not gonna save dynasty
and it's not like it's determining the
outcome of a game no exactly is there
just saying we're not gonna say that
[ __ ] just me making a quick [ __ ]
five grand I'm gonna do right now I'm
talking about
dude I'm excited for this turn down for
what dude I'm really excited
ah feeling special there's so many crazy
prop bets at our good friends bet DSi
Hotlanta oh yeah oh yeah no I'm gonna go
with no on that house I'm gonna go no
because they're both white Super Why -
Super Why will big boy from Outkast be
there will you answer Tony Romo's say
bet against us what all you mean in
terms of like Tony ah Tom Brady be like
everybody's you want yeah you don't
believe in us will watch bet against us
so I'm a total x Roger Goodell will get
shown well I guess again this is during
the actual game because not after the
game when he hands him the trophy
not after the game when he hands
somebody the MVP trophy yeah because
there's there's gonna be two right there
but actually during the game
one-and-a-half is good on that probably
would take I don't think they shown
twice will Michael Vick show up with
Pollyanna and any Chad's been a pleasure
being on the show get the [ __ ] out of
the studio
Pollyanna is the [ __ ] podcast dawg
I think Vick will be there now you know
how I feel when you [ __ ] on my baby oh
come on you don't love that thing
how old's the baby now independence can
to say I love my baby on this [ __ ]
podcast over and under that's a prop
that we should have punched on profit
would be fun that would be fun oh yeah
you like what are there on there what I
have to talk about today okay will Nate
Burleson pick they part is to pick CBS
those is it like the CBS guy who gives a
[ __ ]
they're all picking they're all picking
the Patriots uh-oh ooh Trump will take
part in pregame internal and so on that
one taking no now didn't he have a like
a halftime thing he was doing or
something I must say no oh did you see
that CBS nixed the pot commercial yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] total [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then CBS refused to show
it I bet he does he hates the NFL he
wants to use their radio oh my god does
he ever hate the NFL do dat I felt so
much like this he this is what he wants
well exactly what he would want
oh there's a hundred and forty million
people watching this yeah I'll talk
before half the country's watching is oh
I demand that I get I get to talk for 20
minutes I don't I don't blame him but if
I was the NFL I'd be like suck my dick
[ __ ] you know if I was like you've been
trying to [ __ ] us forever yeah talking
about our ratings being bad when they're
down when they're up you've been
[ __ ] on our beside that this year he
said last year because they were down no
they weren't
yeah they really were last heard they
were yeah they were Oh for they were
down to work the excuse me it was down
during the election year because
everybody's paying true yeah you're a
Baez Trump I would say I'm the [ __ ]
president I want a bubble at on screen
at all time of me watching the game and
promoting the XFL yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
him that's been punch-drunk guys thanks
for calling in [ __ ] why do you have to
say the big game because they'll sue you
that's so [ __ ] nice new you whatever
you have your not unless you have a deal
with them they literally went after I
like a little Church and know where they
said come watch the Super Bowl with us
that's a mafia [ __ ] yeah wait what what
you can't say Super Bowl that means our
show we couldn't go punch-drunk Super
Bowl party we'd have to say super bow or
something like that bow yeah you would
no one can say Super Bowl know you at
the bikini tractor not really grind us
how did it right people to do that
that's a
look up Super Bowl I got in trouble once
wait wait wait wait wait wait a bow it's
all he wants once you know go ahead
we'll circle back no III get a pin in it
so they call it the Super Ball they do
that's what it's called and nobody can
ever say Super Bowl
you can't advertise it oh you mean make
money yeah you can't be like come to my
Super Bowl show you know you can't do
that it's just like legally though
you're not allowed what if I'm having a
Super Bowl party or my buddy's house I
think a big game show I guess we're
gonna try it
I don't know if it's at that level but I
think if you're charging and what we're
gonna do for a second more time Super
Bowl didn't just blame the selling super
game no I was gonna watch it by myself
for $2,000 what were you gonna call it
I was gonna call that watches no Tim
watch the $2,000 sit down I was going to
call it I went to you didn't tell me we
were getting the [ __ ] four grand I
don't know if I knew we were getting
four grand I would have probably just
watched it alone
but you failed to tell me that okay I
love doubts for grants so I got in
trouble no to grant for your half two
grand for my half okay I'm not against
that the Cleveland thought we do use the
Cleveland Kings of Comedy ones yeah and
the guy who owned he owns Kings of
Comedy he searches everywhere for it we
had like paying money and we had to
change the name
yeah and beat off we got yelled at one
time remember remember how you did you
have to make eye contact why you beat on
that's part of the contract remember
whatever the naughty show when we would
do the live one yeah and and every time
you would put me on the flyer for
everyone you always say something stupid
as [ __ ] like for fun crap you KKK member
KKK member like whatever it takes crazy
[ __ ] bad credit and one time it was
whatever that shows no jiggle of what it
was called
yeah that's what the Lowe's and they
[ __ ] hit up Sam and me and like we
this guy's never been on our show like
they were so mad rah
no [ __ ] you dumb [ __ ] the whole show
guys the only person to watch that show
the guys
that show the gigolos was so funny
because it was so contrived and I
remember I did the Iron Sheik oratorio a
gigolo there it was the website that
they use was uh cowboys and angels they
go they use cowboys and angels because
the website ah fat chicks and scumbags
they're also gross pay for any of that
of course not your first of all you're a
girl so you don't have to pay about what
you're doing yeah but they supposedly
get girls like their guy
there's old rich chicks always like oh
they're way older women yeah that's all
like it was all day shift strippers
right yeah she shouldn't be stripping
anymore or will this guy right yes guys
like I tend hold the second guy on the
right looks like the worst one yes he's
the grossest tried to kill Bruce Willis
in the 80s he looks like he only comes
to photos of himself I like to call that
my future yeah Minnesota a video podcast
called Sarge report Sarge
yeah okay and I've never met them in
person up until this week bar I've done
their podcast a lot so I've never seen
them yeah I see this of like the Skype
yeah so they're like hey we're coming to
the Late Show so all you've Skyped into
their pocket got you got you so I'm like
okay cool but you know your show shows
up you're like trying to get shirts
you're doing all this crazy [ __ ] right
yeah so this is why you're at Bronson's
getting gig yeah so I see this like
really good-looking couple hanging out
and I'm like wow that's a really good
couple I don't even think it probably
come to the show and they're just
getting liquored like she's getting
liquored and she's got huge huge rack
sometimes she makes eye contact me she
doesn't look she looks away I'm like
okay so I do my show that chick [ __ ]
heckles me right here super Dez heckles
get super tits drunk as [ __ ] heckling me
right
yeah call her call after the show I get
a text hey man uh it was good seeing you
at ciao
sorry dingo were you guys there and then
I realized that was my friends who had
showed up and for some reason ding come
up we go hey it's it's sergeant Missy
only time they talked to you was when
they were heckling you once no he didn't
he's great yeah she I mean that's the
only contact they was drunk and heckle
me my own friends heckled me so I felt
so bad because I like I just you know
right before a show you're in like
[ __ ] chaos right yeah
so I decided to the podcast Sunday it
was a [ __ ] storm this [ __ ]
Nigerian guy picks me up named Mohammed
in his beat-up [ __ ] van we're just
like sliding all over the place oh it
was a literal story dude it was I
thought you met the show was like great
I crushed the weirdest thing is is I
realized I've been playing tin foil hack
shows so much
I'm just got my fans are there so I
could say well yeah you're playing in
Coors Field the wind blowing out yeah
yeah so then I go to you know minute
Minneapolis and like I'm looking out and
there's dudes and flannels just like
hugging like large farmer chicks yeah
and they're just like I think like I
wore my Carlson Heil sagen shirt yeah
which looks like a slayer shirt which
had like the pentagram behind it so I
had to wear jacket over that because I
go this might [ __ ] with people's heads
really might not know yeah dude it like
that's like hick I mean it's like
they're not hits they're just Midwestern
people yeah why'd you point at me
because that's your I live in LA
resident I pay taxes here it was so I
got heckled by my own friends more
importantly I'm gonna be at that Club
March 8th through the 10th headlining
dude dude god damn it about that I
really got to talk about this if this is
really what we want to do we realize
he's [ __ ] crazy and like how can we
get this Russian kid back to Russia
that's what I'm feeling right now but it
was funny but so I did their pockets is
great I told him I go you guys are way
more [ __ ] than I've ever met of any
podcast
people like most podcast people are
completely unfair we go what are the
most [ __ ] podcasts out there oh
that's a great question what okay you're
putting firing kid up there I'm putting
the Sarge I'll report on there they're
[ __ ] great really yeah is there
anybody that's small a friendship
festival friendship is a [ __ ]
podcast of all time is there any podcast
that has children on it that's not what
he said she has a nine month old cuz
then let's exclude them unless they're
hot come up on Facebook
punch struck podcast remember yeah that
is the Josh Martin podcast no wonder I
wasn't here for that yeah obviously
whatever podcast Kate Quigley's on is
probably way down dr. Phil oh by the way
dude
by the way guys I think that we should
oh it's called Sarge approved my
apologies not sergeant
it's called Sarge approved I'm gonna
tell you guys that I think we had I was
look at his chips jugs it likes to
heckle Sam yeah you can't see yeah dude
big he's good look good she's got rack
you can't see you're great and they're
wonderful people in a couple yeah
they're couple they make love to each
other yeah I asked if I could watch them
[ __ ] to go where geez been on it people
three downloads [ __ ] wow they're killing
it dude being that website to be fair
what is pi hey chip hey can you and
Aaron this is for you can we
reclassified this podcast take it off of
comedy put it on sports what put it on
lifestyle more of a lifestyle I think I
think we'd be ranked higher fee went
sports
it's like Vanderpump rules and us can we
put this on health and fitness
healthy famous dead in ten years
okay so ten years god I hope I don't
live that long ah the fact the thought
of living at ten more years makes me
want to kill myself today you can't have
two tags it could only be sports or
comedy no I say we go please 300 we
probably already have both we should
definitely I'll support one I regret
that we didn't pick your ad like with
all my life oh you look terrible look
like [ __ ] remember I had highlights for
a week
that was from the Icehouse speaking of
Ted Bundy that was from the gig we did
at the ice huh where are those glasses
just done no who's that super jugs right
there she's pretty hot yeah but let's
see right let's get the fun bags out in
it dude they're my friends stop talking
about her tits for the [ __ ] thought
well I'm giving her a compliment you're
talking about her fun bags that's my
friends girl's zip dad banger yes he
doesn't look you can't tell so when I
saw her with big jugs oh my god that's
not her and it was her hey tweet at her
tell her we won baby that was hey maybe
that wasn't her no you're right these
are my friends I feel like I just threw
me in a barracuda of the hottest chick
in Minnesota next to mix words no no the
Minnesota I learned about Mall of
America no matter how weird you look
someone will [ __ ] you that's what I've
learned well the other thing is a freak
show the other thing about that piece
the other thing about that part of the
country is you don't know what you got
Melissa frenzy it's so cold like you
have to dress to survive so you can go
home everybody looks like they weigh 250
and you just keep peeling off the layers
you know I mean the more clothes she
takes off I feel like a hotter shield
and [ __ ] Minister Gaga say no it's
same thing I get that same weather say
do shitty weather hey we stopped let's
talk about your friends tits that you've
been talking Lissa friends we at
everybody tweet at Melissa let it know
tripley once the titty farmer fun way
she has a kid she's a mother she's a
mother
be nice now I gotta kill a child
she's a mother and you're making Chad
uncomfortable she's a mother disgusting
well I mean obviously she's been come
din once that we know it's true to his
credit always these are nice people he
served our country he's a warrior it was
he nice and they're both bow let's let
the Taliban know what's the podcast
about giving them a positive plug oh
it's a great pocket about a bunch of
times they have some great people on and
they just discuss like they're heard
jugs
oh they're G no besides I'm out call
today thank you guys let's get into some
other [ __ ] oh [ __ ] about all the friends
you got it's a pic I'm going Rams so my
and I think it's about three points
right is that what it is really you can
take the points I'm taking the [ __ ]
no Rams are getting three I don't want
them I don't even need them oh go go go
go go go go go here are we doing which
will be hired trumps approval rating or
Jason Tebow by halftime but I'm Bing I
would take me on that that is a what a
weird I mean you want to talk about how
bad DSi has gotten so deep on on a Pratt
bets which will be hired trumps approval
rating on February 4th or the yardage of
the longest made field goal that's such
a specific crazy profit I don't even
know what I would do on that I'll take
right I'm gonna go Rams as well what's
the promo code on this thing about DSi
much 25 good question and what does it
get you at 25 $3 to bet with what do we
need Chad to beat the most professional
guys
we've been doing it for so long and
Chad's beating his early morning radio
knowledge to our show and really
streamlining it this guy was just being
as racist as he possibly could have been
on the second yeah I mean we had to cut
it out so you guys will never hear yeah
because he remember guys were not even
telling the joke right now we had to cut
it out he goes I literally hate n words
and we go you can't see that Chad I did
we cut it out you never say anything
like wow we had to cut that out here the
story about this but you know how was
your bow yeah and you called into the
show so I could J Singh and Sam were
hanging out and I called they said I was
on the show and then Jason Carr
screaming the n-word and I'm like you
can't say that and next thing you know
they're saying I said it and all the
Twitter followers are tweeting and
tweeting and tweeting we go should we
release the audio you thought we were
here we're just driving around in his
car he thought was like a year and a
half ago so few years I had friends back
home they're like dude I did you say the
n-word onna I go now they're just
[ __ ] so I'm up for a radio gig
because we take the call in the car hey
you're live on the air and it goes oh hi
everybody and then we're like you know
and then Tebow goes full Tebow yeah I'm
gonna say we know it was you that said
it yeah but then we got blaming him he
goes I never said that whoever's listen
to this show I did it and we were not
even live you guys got me to say like
two years no no I remember what you said
it you came in drawn off I've only been
drunk at night on patreon this was an 11
I don't know about that I would get
drunk don't go yet Johnny wait what did
Johnny do say Johnny just said the
n-word you were talking about how your
mom didn't want you to bang black guys
and it was like this long rant you went
on and how much you loved black dick at
that point you were talking about that
would sound racist it sounds like I'm
defensive but no he was racist so I
ended up losing a radio gig in Chicago I
was up for a radio gig cuz they did a
little search engine and it's all that
came up but the best I guess I carry
what a racist hold up Chad go Chad
what's going on do you need me like to
defend you and [ __ ] like that like it
got so serious yeah and I couldn't stop
laughing
people like true I'll stop listen to
punk joke if you don't [ __ ] put out
the audio I'm like dude I don't know yet
god damn it yeah it wasn't on all the
black kids were getting shot by cops so
every racial tension was at a halt I'm I
so this program director puts my name
and he goes what the [ __ ]
okay I think Kaepernick was kneeling
because of you I'm a can't you rather be
doing radio and Chicago dead-end or by a
temporary peace I'm the one the gray
sports podcast ever talks to lifestyle
podcast lifestyle fitness I know I it's
that old industries dead and it's just
it's a no-brainer
so we in a weird way we saved you by
announcing how Isis you are you saved my
life
okay all I gotta say to use you're
welcome okay hundred percent yeah
although living in Chicago would have
been fun yeah now would you throw me
having fun right now no I tell you why
he wouldn't Chad why do you have an i
watch you're a [ __ ] pod hua or
whatever that's called an apple about
what it is for why do you have that dude
because I don't need that it tells him
how many [ __ ] sandwiches he's had my
workout wasn't there no that's messed up
man No
Melissa frenzies listening a new segment
called Chad's
favorite subjects LeBron James we're
getting into LeBron jo0 my sermons I'm
going Rams Patriots I don't want him to
win I know you're going pages after your
household Patriots fans beat their wives
more than any other I could see I can't
see him doing that but I can't see him
having reasons to do it can you beat her
for me yeah I can see Jeff being like
God I wish I was more of a scumbag
because I [ __ ] really give you what
you're coming to you just don't talk
back
that larezo picture show that to Sam do
you have it on you David yeah I should
see if he can call it dude
yeah we should we should GSP to Colin
let's go to the phones Nick and Nate
Diaz there's a photo of Nick and Nate
Diaz hanging out with the clip csps best
friend we David laws oh we're mint we
have so many injuries and we don't have
a franchise guy dude next year's gonna
be [ __ ] the Lakers have a franchise
guy and you're still in better shape I
know controvert send it to Johnny I just
wanted you to know that Chad just looked
at his time like he's going how much
longer is this no I just looked at my
[ __ ] things he has a text is gonna
get laid later cuz that wow thank you
thank you new recipes do order Dionne
Warwick know what the recipes Dionne
Warwick she's not dead name of the
Cincinnati Bengals guy who played for
the who played for many bagels bengals
who played for Florida State
Warwick I
time war done work done didn't claim for
the Bengals young work done yeah
LeBron James let's talk about it now the
whole thing and now there's so much
weird [ __ ] going on with LA right
so if LA loses a Super Bowl boss and
beat us twice in championship games in a
year right now if Anthony Davis comes
the Lakers the Lakers had [ __ ] New
Orleans twice and within a two-week
period that's that's interesting that's
some weird [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
I so hope he doesn't come to the Lakers
I don't want LeBron to have a [ __ ]
you know what I do like no matter what
talk to me getting ball out of town I
hate that guy hate his whole family
I like ball haters I like balls too ugly
he is ugly but I do like him I don't
like his family his dad's so dumb we're
not gonna go to New Orleans you're going
wherever we tell you to go
he's a Kris Kardashian to me who's now
it's a good analogy I like that that's a
good analogy he ball for the win I mean
it's right
yeah and I hate her and I hate him
morning ray she loves black dude he's
black yeah you [ __ ] balls of the
Kardashians get the [ __ ] on morning
radio dude you get bonuses for good
analogies that's why chad said that yeah
like an old school thing do create an
algae here's your dollars $5 bonus yeah
five bonus caller number Five's gets
free tickets to the great American rib
burn off from Marx we're about to kick
it off with another non stop block a
foreigner here on punch rug sports where
else where else can you go we'll just
talk about trading the eyebrow okay so
unibrow New Orleans would be dumb to
make this trade right now yeah unless
they get everything they want me to the
Lakers are in Lakers because Boston can
make a better deal at the end of the
year once the season is over it's the
deal well they could send you like
anybody but Kyrie or and Boston has all
those picks - well there's a lot of pics
they can give up and now everybody
thinks that Kyrie wants to go back and
play with LeBron because he's been like
doing and they've been talking now he
wants to you want to reopen in boss
yeah Kairi is not going anywhere it's my
point
but yeah so I agree with that if why
Reese days in Boston he's not going
anywhere I mean he's been talking about
maybe he wants to go to New York I think
he would stay in Boston my dumb believe
he's the best organization that's coach
warm bread Steven he likes it it's his
team he likes it there it seems and they
will get him players there that's one
thing about Danny Ainge he's not he
works smart
outside of Jerry West I trust him the
second most yeah it's the guy from
Oklahoma the OKC Thunder yeah like he's
do good coach they know not coach
gyah like their ability to get people to
come to Oklahoma and how they do that is
unbelievable that team should be worse
in Memphis the fans there it's almost
like a college atmosphere well because
they got nothing else you have the
Sooners and OKC
basketball yeah so I mean they should
have left Seattle that's total [ __ ]
yeah I would trade them all that for him
dude
do you remember Tebow spray-painted the
n-word on LeBron garage oh I totally
remember that by the way was there ever
a picture that today when ever see the
picture the cameras went out yeah video
cameras actually went out I heard that
Hillary Clinton did it no I heard he did
it himself yeah I would I would it is so
much smart they're like the San Diego
rato much smarter to [ __ ] hold up and
just I want them to [ __ ] the Lakers so
badly
I love the Lakers I love Magic Johnson I
hate LeBron James I'm with you like him
as a player I just hate what he does
he's are trying to get rid of Luke
Walton which we all knew he was gonna do
this is LeBron being LeBron and what
LeBron will do is when it all implodes
on him he'll blame everybody but him he
hasn't been a coach since high school
since Dru Joyce I disagree with that I
think in Miami he the reason one in
Miami is because you know what Pat Riley
stepped in because he was trying to get
now I go what's his name fire too yeah
he goes pair I says [ __ ] you in the
clique you claim I'm [ __ ] Pat Riley
I've done everything you've done
more and that's why I'm dude I
personally nobody got this analogy but
LeBron James reminds me of a comic who
comes from a smaller scene and comes LA
and tries to pull his describing me
right now no no no who tried to pull his
like games that worked in like his small
comedy scene where he was able to like
[ __ ] do the magic shell game on
people yeah yeah it's like you're in a
shark tank dog you're not the only shark
here so when you're on the Lakers
okay LeBron you're not even the best
player to ever play there there's guys
walking around there that have won more
rings in you yeah so this [ __ ] you're
pulling that none of them pulled isn't
gonna fly with anybody yeah as a LeBron
James expert who burned his jersey
before he left for Miami I'd like to get
a little credit on that okay I was the
original hater do we give him credit do
you give him credit for that I haven't
listened to anything anybody said in the
last 20 minutes but he would pull [ __ ]
in Cleveland I got stories for days like
his people his mom they would go down to
the like platinum bar and they just
order a round of drinks and just leave
they wouldn't even charge it they
wouldn't leave a tip she tried to do
that Miami wait a minute a black eye
didn't tip in a restaurant and I bet you
Dave low on some [ __ ] tips I just
gave him the number so he might be
calling oh we got a guess GSP my way
because right and Nate Diaz I'm loving
[ __ ] narco Nick Diaz huh like that
guy looks straight out of narco right
does not look good everybody in that
photo does know Nikki Diaz hanging out
with you the new name narco Diaz hanging
out with you David laws about crazy The
Crow best friend you would tell me cuz
you know Chad's come on the show and
broke a lot news Baker Mayfield's
bisexual we all know that for sure
and then he's broke the news that Chad
broken news that Chad knows the guy who
gave LeBron James HGH and actually had
the needle yeah has his DNA on it and
that threatened LeBron James
this blackmail you mean basically LeBron
wasn't paying the guy goes listen if
you're not gonna pay me I'm just gonna
go I got all your evidence right here
I'm gonna go to the forensics people and
it's gonna get you out there and they
basically paid him and went with another
hdhk die they dumped him
Chad's breaking news yeah I hear I got
my ear to the streets a guy I know
people that know him remember the room a
naughty guy doesn't even break this
[ __ ] news what kind of a kind of
rumors you know about Aaron over there
yeah other than his wife other than his
wife who's leaving him and I am sorry
bro that's foul other than his wife
who's leaving them what what you kind of
mean breaking hot tips on Aaron listen
I'm working on people one person at a
time okay so you're gonna do once you're
done destroying LeBron SiC your dogs on
Aaron over there that guy's nothing else
of juice he's dabbling in everything
that's come up of a die-hard Cavs fan
you brought me my first championship
ever I'm still on to this [ __ ] I
know for a fact that Aaron sells drugs
to children that's [ __ ] up
neighborhood you know where he stuffs
the drugs in the stuffed-crust pizza
that's the order stuck I get some stuff
cross deposit actually cause it problem
is Aaron always eats the pizza and you
there's never any pizza left for the
kids I'm willing to bet right now yeah
all of our money from bet Dias I go to
bed ts I used a cup of punch 25 I'm
going to bet that Aaron right now has
crack in his pee hole
Aaron bring it out that's let's spread
that [ __ ] flap her wings open let's
see what you got lady in the room baby's
a drug mule dude it's not even a real
baby it's just like one of those like
Russian tags you can open up and there's
another smaller one and they're like a
pinata of drugs her baby dude and all
the drugs that's what that's what makes
sense cuz she's like hey I don't know my
baby's walking at one month she's a
miracle child yeah you mean a robot by
the way you know what I got out of this
whole conversation I want a pizza shop
to sponsor punch-drunk I want pizza
well you said you should say you see our
sponsor Burger King pizza is code for
pedophilia so watch yourself Chad cuz
you could be out of here yeah let's get
a pizza sponsor
are you serious bro because I'm saying
in Sam let's get a pizza sponsor wink
wink
I mean let's get some of that delicious
sex Ibiza mushroom on goats do you think
ad goes to the Lakers Jason Tebow LeBron
does go to liquors no ad I I don't know
I if it means trading ball I hope so so
you hate I just hate this whole family
your hatred of ball you hate them more
than your hatred of the Lakers no no no
but but it's claiming him or he's my
least favorite Laker okay he's my least
favorite player on my least favorite
team okay I respect I look at that
delicious child guys have a good one
it's been a fun time you're going to
hole what I had what an [ __ ] hey
Johnny can you pull up LeBron's Sports
Illustrated when he was coming home I
want you to read how much of a [ __ ]
hypocrite this guy is everyone should
hate his guts in Cleveland coming home
pudding coming home [ __ ] coming see Tom
him and me you ing look at he wouldn't
even do that he wouldn't even [ __ ]
put incoming
he'd rather put in returning I'm coming
home yeah what's hypocritical now let's
let's uh okay I won't read the whole
thing we've all wrapped yeah we hate
your reading yeah shut up
scroll down and [ __ ] I went to okay he
said I'm at the my mat keep going oh
okay here we go when I left Cleveland I
was on a mission I was seeking
Championships we won - but Miami already
knew that feeling our city hasn't had
that feel in a long long time my goal is
still to win as many titles as possible
no question but the most important one
for me is bringing a trophy back to
Cleveland he did okay that's okay
alright I always believed that I would
return to Cleveland finished my career
there I just didn't know when after the
season and free agency even though I
thought with my boys and girls Savannah
and I pregnant she was pregnant with our
little girl I started like I read I like
it I it's getting I read like [ __ ]
slower Hey as judge on this case
he goes I started thinking what would be
like to raise my family in my hometown I
looked at dude he's [ __ ] [ __ ] he
wanted he's basically trying to take all
the good Cleveland by the way yeah this
is from a guy who left Cleveland just
yeah but the city doesn't care about me
half my peers hate my guts you think
I'll a does dude he came into the right
time I'm back guys I got more coffee but
what I'm saying is like the downtown
business depended on this dude we didn't
have anything this guy was the biggest
thing we had no I heard that when he let
all joking aside I heard that when he
left that it costs like 40 million
dollars or something around there and
there's like just in parking alone yeah
just in parking alone not selling out
that stadium of him being gone [ __ ] them
and out of money no the whole downtown
area I was talking to one of the
bartenders down there they're like yeah
we make more money off the Lake Erie
Monsters which is a minor-league [ __ ]
hockey team compared to the Cavs right
well you know I hear that like when
LeBron leaves
Ares monsters so when LeBron James
leaves I hear that people actually start
to eat homeless people because it's so
bad really when the Cleveland Google
that hey I heard the amount of children
they get raped it goes way down way down
way down down down it's at about Sam's
quitting the show wow that's amazing
are you serious I had to look up like it
might be true but then I was like know
what that you're in coffee go get coffee
check come back come back
Chad come back little baby about guys
check out my new podcast see you have
come pick our Patriot I don't know how
many you have this you have this behind
you every time you talk on the phone
with this guy hi Chad
you won the NBA one yeah and that's it
no and then I have my contrition yeah
and you're yeah and two patrons I like
did you live on the Internet I live on
the internet stocks do you ever talk
about stacks do you ever talk to anybody
without a microphone yeah without being
online
I am success you gotta give that to me
like how many hours throughout the day
you talk to somebody without a
microphone yeah well not online how many
conversations too much you feel less
crazy if you have a microphone in front
of you because about me I talk to myself
all [ __ ] so I might as well just
record it I'm talking anyway why let
this gold go away I'm gonna do it
anyways my brain is crazy I can't stop
talking myself I might as well retorted
sure that's literally making me one
pizza what that photo every time I look
at I'm gonna I'm literally gonna do that
today I had pizza in Minnesota with the
the the [ __ ] couple oh really
yeah same what do you mean her son was
there not cool I don't agree with that
why do you ain't their child I'm sorry
Sam why do you call super tits and
little dick that's why I don't come he's
jacking his hyung dick so we have a
discussion uh Johnny thinks that Zion
Williams is gonna [ __ ] the bed in the
NBA he said he what did Johnny say he
sucks dick because he doesn't think he's
good god he hates him
Johnny hates some dude anybody who comes
out Duke
Johnny hates Kearney you did say that
Johnny Johnny you did say Johnny once
said that [ __ ] said that
no I didn't Johnny defend your point
what positions are you gonna play in the
NBA
I think he's gonna play maybe a power
too yeah I agree with their knowledge
he'll play him at 2-2 and he's gonna be
a strong one I was having an argument
last night I was having this argument
last night with somebody to go look at
him right now
he
a better shot then then Blake Griffin
did when Blake was in college I agree
with that Jason t-bob better
so if Blake can't break it is LeBron
couldn't shoot when he got into the NBA
he was a Drive guy there's nobody I
disagree that Lake was a hundred percent
address I reminds me of Shawn Kemp this
game with where's the shooting guard
he's fine and he's also 40 pounds
heavier than the shooting guard can
shoot look up Shabazz Muhammad dude look
up Shabazz Muhammad look up that guy he
played for the temple look up Muhammad
Ali - just for fun just look up
Muhammad's in general dude look up
Shabazz Muhammad he's 285 he's 285 and
he's [ __ ] he was at his prom four
months ago
four months ago he was at his high
school [ __ ] drama okay power guard
they called him I don't know where he
plays right now oh I think he's out of
the league but dude he's just one of
those got what yeah he's just one of
those guys making that China money yeah
but he's just one of those guys that
just went to the wrong team and look up
look up Gabe male gay porn look that
[ __ ] up ah stop stop stop don't look
that up because we'll get kicked off
some who and what is Blake was Blake
shooting his when he was in college who
would you compare him to Zion Williams
his game right now who would you compare
him to his game Barkley I could see that
really Barkley was six six he's six
seven
I mean this guy can jump out of the
goddamn gym nobody plays Steve it to the
NFL I don't mean in the NBA dude he's
he's gonna play defense in the NFL up he
goes down the [ __ ] lane
nobody's gonna block him also no legs I
stopped at we play he great shot blocker
great body what are you gonna how you
gonna move a 300-pound guy
for ten years at least put them up with
the good probably gonna get even soccer
balls please
Chicago Bulls I'm begging you please
dangling you and the Knicks are gonna
get oh please whoever I if you get a
good point guard with that dude it's
gonna be Showtime any self Jersey
he sells jerseys that's that's also the
side name of this episode ah
did you watch the Bellator out so we're
done with the NBA no I was just talking
man well I just want to say we like that
half-hour um do you your Chicago your
Cleveland Clippers - and Knicks are my
second team clips in my second two clips
are my number one teacher my second
what's your number one team it's a
pretty tied Clippers cuz I'm here yeah
and the Bulls are bad and Clippers are
doing all right but I you know I root
for both of them
if they were both were in the finals
which will never happen in my lifetime I
I would be torn I'll be torn
I am uh I I think they're gonna put I
don't think they'll let Cleveland get
another another number was we had like
nine of them they're all none of them
are on the team anymore
and Cleveland must beat the Bulls you
had four cleon just beat the Bulls I was
so happy
well Cleveland just beat the Bulls by
like Tannen yeah we have LeBron Kyrie
and your boy was about it yes he's
yelling at me that he's trying to call
just an FYI hey do it open up the
[ __ ] phone line because GSP calling
in everybody's getting angry you don't
want an angry he's already angry yes
dude is out magical listen to this it's
hard to call into this place they got to
fix it he's already mad are you talking
[ __ ] about magical
no I don't know him he said you see that
camper out there is high quality it's
for us to hang out it's supposed to be
like a legit camp scene is that right
have bill burr call in he said he's
gonna put benches I mean I'm down for
the food part you should get some pizza
yeah that pizza and children just
hanging out there all the time right who
wants to be tempted so Sam's you watch
Bellator
okay I love that we're already done with
try that [ __ ] transition oh into the
phone it's on yo hello your unshrunk
who's this hello this is example to hear
him think I hear him but I can barely
hear him yes yes P we hear you where is
he pissing Aaron quit the show Aaron
quit the [ __ ] show just went on
number one calling gasps now the Chad's
on the show this is the this is the
number one unprofessional podcast ever
oh we have a professional calling in and
your [ __ ] drop in deuces oh there you
go
please love to show I'd say a top four
of all time mm a superstar and number
one caller number one caller top four
wherever he's in that top four is up to
your debate I have them on my Mount
Rushmore please I haven't right there
with LeBron okay please welcome GSP
everybody thank you very much today a
tough day for me I'm kind of fed now why
you sad George my best friend put in a
picture with the disgusting dear brother
yeah no there is a photo of the de
Valera's oh the CRO your best friend
hanging out with your two enemies the
Diaz brothers they did bury you in a
refrigerator box I do recall that with
nothing but your cell phone and your
belt that's a mouthful for a nickname
that is a what what's what's the
nickname again David is no longer best
friend
but the good news is associate finding
that no one has to say it because he
does not fight now what was he doing
with with the do you know what why he
was hanging out with the Diaz brothers
or what they were actually doing look
like they were having a great time
[Laughter]
whatwhat's he going through besides I
apparently hanging out with the Diaz
brothers maybe smoking some pot and I
think there's no I don't know if I would
necessarily agree with that I know the
Diaz brothers are pretty proud of
Stockton narco Diaz yeah but yeah so so
he's pretty much getting rid of kitty
litter cuz it's too intense for me wants
to dumb it down a little bit to some pop
[Music]
I did hear that yeah it's so ridiculous
George what's going on in the dinosaur
world the dinosaurs to come would you
hear these rumors from aliens have you
been talking on the air they aliens been
talking to you again
wow it sounds like you're really hurt by
by your best friend hanging out with
your number one and number two enemies
the guys that pretty much catfished you
three times stole your girl buried you
alive in a refrigerator box etc etc
what you're Tony cheating with the three
of them hang out because none of that
I've ever worn a belt around our waist
hold on real quick for a second Chad
isn't even listening this interview with
a one of the greatest MMA fighters he's
watching himself on the livestream Chad
act like you've been there okay yes this
is one of the biggest podcasts in the
world yes this is an amazing moment in
your career I understand all that but
you're on with one of the greatest MMA
fighters ever and you're watching
yourself on a live stream to Lake Erie
Monsters you dumb [ __ ] good call back
Chad were you not Chad huh tell me this
right now were you not watching yourself
on your the live stream that never
happens yeah you're lying Chad dude
you're lying
get over yourself Chad be part of the
show or we're gonna replace you have GSP
on the line right GSP on the line right
now
Oh shot at Klaw [ __ ] Steve a is a
good dude nah a head Cleveland Jessica
eyes a good lady Oh God just guys like 3
and 9 in the UFC she's fighting for a
belt by the way he's the [ __ ] by the way
most ofrenda Bowl UFC fighter album I
get on the phone right now
I get on the cam right ahh she wouldn't
be my number one
she's my Jessica dick I know just guys I
know there's a video if you go to my
YouTube page I arm rustler did you ever
see it it's relevant the conversation we
got GSP on the phone you're like hey
guys check out my myspace page and while
you're out to pick up my new album my
white guy named Chad on iTunes who wants
me to go to Chad Zuma at Friendster
where we get it bro exactly Thank You
GSP of course you did so talk to us dude
are you gonna have a face-to-face with
David lawanda are you gonna have to have
a sit-down with the crow or I'm sorry
David
who's not longer best friends with
George st. Pierre Louis Oh David steps
foot back in Montreal I have a bounty on
his head
oh and I would imagine how many jean
shorts are you willing to pay to kill
David Luiz oh hey Tina well I hear
that's a lot of iron that's the legal
mind of George st. Pierre now George can
we get like a maybe an audio or the
sound bite of you no one's asked you
this yet in person but there are rumors
that you are going to be the next one to
fight [ __ ] what's the name Norma get
off Sam where you going really
everyone's fighting him yeah everybody's
but they're saying now that's like it
could be George's next fight deal are
you about to fight khabib or do you have
a fight plan in order of who you're
going to fight next I will fight the
Diaz brothers maybe you should have a
tuna fight against the crow or I mean no
longer friends with George st. Pierre I
think I would be better off well I love
to see you fight Chad Zuma George I'd
like to train for something that'd be
fun should used to be training to get
murdered I would like to work out like
you can do that anytime you want really
yeah you don't need
if you'd like to work out you could just
work out you don't need to get murdered
at the end of your workout but I like
the goal I competition yeah what's your
wait what's this what's your way dude
how about that you know what it's
getting real now I gotta shut this
Midwest body I'm going to curves well
yeah but what do you what are you
knocking around in video 225 I'm 218 all
right right in there yeah I mean George
what about you five nine in heels and
Doc Martens phew being mean is so out of
character but he's really pissed because
I mean I've noticed that the Diaz
brothers have always been targeting you
George is that true or false the way he
shits on his current workout as weird as
like why does Nick do you think of you
so much also Nate swims-a-lot for cardio
well they both today notorious for death
they do decathlon Nick hasn't worked out
in three well for sure I don't think he
fights again no Nate well nothing Nate
well how do they make their money we'd
remember public appear when I was there
naked like handing him $20 it was like
the saddest thing I've ever seen you
know what so clearly he wasn't six
minutes ago [ __ ] tripley tweets out
I'm not
I wanna promote the dude you were
tweeting people yeah
I'm six minutes ago my show I was gonna
say he is the leader of the show he can
do whatever I'm not real happy and then
your liking photos on Instagram he's I
guarantee you he's made for fliers since
the show he took his computer away when
he went like we're all gonna sabotage
the show we're too busy today he's the
only one he's on the computer more than
Johnny's on the computer ever get on
that job to be on the computer
there's a guest on the phone so uh GSP
what do you think of the whole Bellator
fights probably that's a good discussion
you got a little something right here
other side okay ten minutes ago Sam
Tripoli got it tweeting where was I when
I did that Chad in the bathroom
thank you were right there shut up you
just got back let's go to the day we're
all doing coke I actually have it you
said we've all gone to the bathroom I
haven't I did go get coke and coffee not
wearing a diaper that is like a Bowie
like a Bowie
sorry [ __ ] dude he must [ __ ] on his
balls
all the time Oh disgusting not even oh
yeah if he's sitting on the toilet like
GFP just said oh yeah his balls have to
be in the water so he has to be [ __ ]
on his balls
oh yeah sure let's try to do two
podcasts at once or fight you go ahead
Chad can we kill Chad's mic is that
possible yeah you guys used to cut mine
all the time hey cutter might be careful
cut his mic dude Chad Chad doesn't want
to be on the show anymore sumac it's
Brad sumac around I have I think there's
I just lost yeah we killed tonight yeah
one days are in the penalty box he's in
the talking penalty box everybody he's
done [ __ ]
before you down for five we have a half
an hour to go if we got 23 minutes ago
you can come back if you don't say dumb
[ __ ] okay so uh real quick you pass I
mean yeah we have 23 minutes to the end
the show Chad's got Chad s and not say
something dumb in the next five minutes
or else we start another five minutes
well I'm going to leave for five minutes
go get in the camper go get in the
camper
okay he knows he can't refrain from I
think we're gonna have a silent bow
everybody here should we keep chatting
on the shower killer okay wait what it's
really been rocky what is GSP thing well
GSP your thoughts right now on should
Chad sumach stay a part of the show and
this is also a guy we're talking to by
the way George just lost his best friend
of all time yeah hey can you also put an
arm upon a pole should we keep
challenged oh no he lost to today yo
girl consumed with death but put on a
pole shoot Chad be allowed to stay on
the show is this his first day on his
last day so put the pole out what is
your high I mean we don't want to do
yeah yeah either stays on the show or
dies okay that's the pole does Chad come
back on the show again or never live or
die or die no Chad be a regular and punt
drunk or die I checked George I
understand how emotional you are right
now euler regular makes you a regular
die crying is he lost his best friend
cry best friend to his enemy that's like
if like I started being best friends at
[ __ ] this chat and then I told you to
[ __ ] it I'll find out on social media
like he doesn't even have the balls to
tell you what do you do look at him you
see them under a heat lamp he's like I
know you're G have missed you calling in
sir it's all the colors we need more
callers man well dice colony we should
all dude I want to know what what's his
face from the Tampa Bay Buccaneers dad
Jameis Winston yeah Leroy wins
George you're a fan of the show what was
uh what was a Jameis Winston's dad's
name Anton our Anton our Chad's got two
minutes till he is allowed back on the
mic to make an argument why he should be
made a regular and not die so that's so
sad for GSP right - sounds really
emotional in there with drugs when
you're off of drugs you start to crash
really hard yeah I'm sure that that
kitty litter goes when you get
withdrawals you get withdrawal but it
sounds like he just has withdrawals from
friendship I wish you God
call in with his french-canadian accent
black voice and let us know what he
thinks so if he's out there and he's
listening I wish he would call in I wish
I mean I know he's gonna probably get
the worst side of hanging out with great
if they're doing the same thing to him
is anyone see you David Lewis maybe
they're catfishing you know you're right
maybe they're catfishing him to get to
try to get back in your head George what
do you think about Ronda Rousey in the
WWE yeah you were in love with her for a
while if we recall on the show it's the
same Triple E point yeah this is so
[ __ ] weird dude so [ __ ] weird
Chad's got seven seconds till he's
allowed back on and have we any one
answered the polls yet and we have any
answers on the poll
Chad's back welcome back jack not a bomb
what's going on me too pleased about you
please stop that Chad so it's closed
it's closed it's closed yeah okay can
you um cut his mic he's out of the
penalty but I have your finger up
hovering above that little switch Chad
check checked every on there make it
impassioned plea about why you should be
made of regular and not die well I
definitely shouldn't die okay just get
that out okay decide after your plea
I say we listen real quick you learn
lesson oh I forgot why I was even in the
penalty box dad enough should be back
we're trying to call and do a double
podcast oh yeah stop podcasting why
we're podcasts try to be innovative
who's done that before by the way I
forgot to mention this Saturday night
yeah did you see who went on in the o.r
no Chevy Chase oh I love that
was anybody there I was there how was it
really bad we bomb really bad yes Bob
super Bob does he do comedy or shout I
mean people don't understand what the
Comedy Store is right now more than any
other team in do stand-up he just talked
he just he went up and told like an
old-school bar joke did he fall down
yeah it's funny uh.well told like an old
school bar joke and then talked about
how he doesn't do stand-up anymore or
ever ever and then he goes so just
anybody asked me whatever you want to
ask me and then he just did a QA for
like 12 minutes like that he thinks
people want that I heard he's an [ __ ]
well you want are you got you got that
vibe a little bit really Allah don't get
me wrong I love flash of spies like us I
think they are I think there's a remake
in the works works without William Katt
yeah obviously I liked Caddyshack
Caddyshack yeah sure oh hold on here
hold on foster homes here's the here's
the trailer for Shazam oh it looks
really bad I've seen this when you're 18
give these people a chance cuz that's
what they're giving you this looks
terrible
this is billy batson oh good a crippled
kid my favorite sod your boy Walter
White jr. dude oh you know when I watch
these kids act I think how much dick has
been in each one of these kids oh come
on
screw them I'm sorry I stay away from
this conversation
not enough laughter that is not enough
oh come on nerd
oh [ __ ] this is great great audio spider
in the kid always says this it's my
favorite thing I don't like fast forward
fast forward no I love this it's exactly
a better trouser than the old one you
love one podcast do this stuff dude
we've done two hours we could have a
moment of just listening what what is
she's anime name sir
Shazam it means uh I thought it was the
app where it tells you what song it is
by the way this trailer is much better
than the first round on April think
about it this is about a guy that's a
kid that becomes a superhero his powers
and still hangs out with kids
superpowers and big stuff I'll sing
right okay I'm tired of these first of
all I love Hollywood I'm leaving the
show I love Hollywood because he's gone
this is quick look like a dude like
nanny this quit it's like hey everybody
the writers want to make everybody think
nerds are [ __ ] cool so let's make a
nerd it's like that guy who used to do
the office who is now doing all the
Special Forces movies who's obviously a
dork and could never be a special forces
guy but he's in every food movie now
what about all these movies that were
women are in the workforce
what oh now you are a teacher a teacher
really really the kitchen [ __ ] a woman
Ghostbuster oh dude you see Leslie Jones
is pissed they're doing another colonist
I think Bill Murray's in the third well
yeah they're doing a thorough oh by the
way fun [ __ ] did you watch can you go
find Bill Murray interview with we're
not watching more videos no no stop put
your foot down now
bill how dare you have an opinion about
anything the real
- very bad just [ __ ] basically shits on
the movie
don't worry could be whatever you do
when everyone's you know he doesn't even
have an agent or a manager yeah is
unknowable he has an eight
hundred-number no he's he's due and I
forget it was like ah dr. Phil or one of
those morning shows and he's like man
you watched uh you know you watch these
guys you root for him cuz they're just
trying really hard and you're like oh
god just [ __ ] on the movie pretty what
movie the female version of ghostbusters
I love Leslie Jones I'm super happy for
her I didn't refer to do whatever but
did you see the movie it's terrible it's
terrible I don't know the girls weren't
even the problem they were actually
pretty funny them the plots is terrible
yeah we'll do what you which is a cash
grab
it is a cash grab they making money off
the name of the movie an all-female
thing like we're 20 years into this you
know this this when they get a study and
they found women are 70 percent of
buying power so then they started doing
all this stuff for women right so we are
we're 20 years into seeing commercials
where guys can't wipe their own ass
without a woman helping them like guys
are dumb and women are the smartest
human beings on the planet so guys don't
like to watch this so when you do it all
female show that tells guys oh you don't
need to go see this because the whole
humor is gonna be kicking dudes in the
dick doesn't if it's not that that's
what we think it is that's actually what
I look for in a girl for a girl to wipe
my ass with her face the new trailer I
don't think this is real it is so now
they're pissed
the female cast because they basically
don't even recognize the all-female
version well I mean I get it everybody
wants to work but here they would be
smart to bring the females in because
this will be a good way to introduce
them so it's not an all-female cast and
people will be okay with it it's why
oceans [ __ ] didn't work cuz nobody
believes that twelve chicks could work
together getting buck I don't think I
don't think women should do any
thing other than lay on your back get
knocked off and take it and make me a
[ __ ] sandwich so I hear their
point I hear your point now thirty-four
percent make him a regular 66 I actually
like that for this audience you're gonna
die this isn't bad
I mean we already have 50 votes and a
like almost 70 percent want you to die
Wow how does that make you feel that's
70 percent uh I mean talking 35 out of
50 want you dead that number will get
higher yeah yeah how does that make you
feel how about this if Chad cannot go to
90 percent die I think we bring him back
but the good news is 15 15 people the
good news is 15 people out of 50 Chad
are you want you on this Travis life to
this guy at Bryan or W says he's
hilarious keep him on I like that guy he
knows what he's saying by the way Bryan
is a bot that we made let me just
quickly log in and vote my vote as well
hey can we switch gears back to
pedophilia yeah he's just suck you just
just sucked dude like my reading Chad
they don't like it so are you gonna see
that Michael Jackson documentary oh I
hear it's crazy yeah it basically says
he's a pedophile letting this one on
it's gonna be on HBO it's four hours
fits for now we take on black takes two
which is really weird what do you mean
HBO's programming now is all black it's
going like vh1 LeBron show but whatever
on there happened Green stood up Queen
that's done they got a new sketch show
coming out this the [ __ ] all their
specials are like [ __ ] black comics
now I mean they just had this chick who
does a morning show who's completely
racist she's so [ __ ] races against
white people and they always put that
out it's just the way it is dude so it
sounds like it sounds very damning one
member vh1 where arm vh1 was all like
rock videos now it's like it's like hot
black chicks which I have
obisam black but you see how white it's
getting now no but once gameofthrones
gone I mean so going back to the Michael
Jackson thing okay I met BT speaking of
white P by the way if it's hot black
chick so beat it
I know do you beat it there you go
Michael Jackson that's racist by the way
anyone think that's his daughter she's
got no that's not her dad like it but
she's like I'm making so much money do
you think he [ __ ] touch kid dude he
doesn't interview with this one [ __ ]
Indian reporter who at does have the
balls and check him he's like I just
like this yeah so what we drink I get
the milk and we sleep together and I
love them she's hottest by the way
that's that's not a bad Michael Jackson
a break at all that she's so there's no
God in that cream I'd [ __ ] Michael
Jackson's kids her [ __ ] again he was
born black I would lick those kids not
her kids so yeah you would [ __ ] Michael
Jackson's kid but we want to grow kids
yeah yeah okay yeah like that looks
exactly like him I could totally see it
she should do her 23 he's got big
titties she's got the same tits as I do
she saw doing with a big ass cute face
guy I liked it yeah but what don't
forget about that podcast super tits and
what's his face that small she look like
comedian Erin darling I don't know who
that is but I'll just win up I mean she
looks like a [ __ ] uh no keep her
there
we're by the way we were looking up
Miley Cyrus pictures of Michael
Jackson's daughter to it like champions
why is Erin darling why Sebastian
Maniscalco in that feed why not yeah she
looks like you're right it's like they
kind of look alike and I would lick both
her [ __ ] and put that in the bank
Betty si.com use the code punch 25 and
you can make a prop bet well Sammy
either one of these chicks [ __ ] will
I be allowed to see what
would I is enough yeah but probably a
shot at you know the one on the right
Michael Jackson Tartars probably got a
lot of red tape to get to her I bet you
I got better too many documentaries have
you watched the what's-her-name head by
everyone is not Ted Bundy just had funny
one because finish this morning walking
in you know what it really reminds you
or you never thought of how easy it was
to be a criminal in the 700 it's
technology if you ran away with
everything this can't get away with [ __ ]
anymore
this dude was jumping on planes getting
IDs stole like a car every day broke out
of jail twice and every time he broke
out of jail would just murder
[ __ ] no wow
if we hadn't let him walk around the
library and he just jumped out the
window and he killed a kid should be a
poet 12 year old killed a 12 year I'll
bet will El Chapo get a scape from the
jail he's at a Supermax in Devon I don't
think there's a way but this was like
the 70s was like so easy to do what
they're like he just stole a car you
know why how he stole it because the
keys were just in the ignition it was
unloved yeah no one lost a friend no one
did anything in the 70s that could walk
in your house make a sandwich you come
home be like oh he is literally the
reason Ted Bundy is literally the reason
why it's not like that anymore
yeah and school shooters and mass
shooters are now the new serial killer
you know there were never serial killers
that look like the same [ __ ] purse
there weren't serial killers and then in
the 70s there was like eight of them
like that was the new way that evolution
was getting that population control was
being handled by Darwinism you're right
about the school shooters though cuz how
else would you kill someone more than
months there's no no that's because no
one has the time to spend Monday killing
people one at a time I love her my only
problem right now is Netflix is making a
lot of money off [ __ ] serial killers
and murderers but yeah they're not
paying them at least a comic they say
some one thing wrong but yeah the
special bed dude is that yours
what the hell I thought he was just
making a point I was making a point is
that a bit here let's switch spots
switch spots I'm back on the [ __ ]
show I'm back
yeah that's head-butting one's nuts yeah
we're gonna start that yeah it's there's
a fully four episodes and they're about
like 45 minutes each not quite four
hours but it's [ __ ] [ __ ] good one
[ __ ] what is this what's happening
what's a pizza yeah yeah yeah you mean
delicious children by the way that guy
went to a went to a naughty show I have
a picture with him who Ted Bundy or Zac
Efron Oh Ted Bundy broke out of jail
which I gotta get to the naughty shelf I
gotta kill me some [ __ ] I think he
got the chair I think he died he did get
to chair it was a gigantic event
represented himself proposed to a
witness and got engaged while he
proposed to a witness on the stand
represent himself completely [ __ ]
himself it's fascinating
okay last meal let's go around the horn
your last meal oh my roll from [ __ ]
sushi Roku okay burger I'm going large
dude I'm [ __ ] bankrupting California
dude
mine's easy to potential shocker -
Mexican food I might I might go like a
real good authentic chicago-style deep
dish that's good daddy like all of our
answers like matchup you know how that
almost kills me every time I would eat
that so if you get the chair that just
goes everywhere like yeah but you don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] I know that's I'm
saying like that's [ __ ] great just
[ __ ] mop up yeah yeah that's what you
get for killing me Chipotle I probably
wouldn't just go like glass of water and
like yeah
100% I'd haven't like a salmon salad
with balsamic vinaigrette no no oil and
vinegar cuz you know no carbs watch my
figure
how's happening that's what happens when
you say you're gonna replace him listen
if you read the tension hey everybody
not into a mic nothing I guess that's it
I encourage you to watch this instead of
listening it's a very visual podcast go
Rams head up my patreon